all right
welcome everybody
hello andy how are you
it's uh amazing to see live people
really
so
today we are going to talk about
performance testing or how to break it
and make it better right
this session i'm going to touch my
promise at the end of the session i will
ask you did i
get
to the point of teaching you
why performance testing is important
why should we use k6 it's a proper
alternative
and also teach you how to use k6 until
you can build a proper
seemingly real-life end-to-end
performance test
so that's my promise to you at the end
of the sessions you will get that so
take it as a bit of a bit of fun session
and also a bit of a learning which is
meant to be fun
so
who i am my name is jose luis latorre
i'm a spanish born in barcelona but
working in switzerland in swiss life
living the swiss life
my twitter id is g-o-s-l-e-t
that is made from a first part of three
letters of my name
j-o-s and l-a-t and that's the same for
github
i've been aborted 9 times as a microsoft
mbb
suddenly we're good in the middle but
i'm getting back to public speaking so
we'll see and i'm a software architect
at swiss life also coding a lot and a
developer community lead making or
helping
the developers to have fun while doing
great work and getting better at what
they do
also in my private life i'm also
publicly speaking and
leading the dotnet user group at zurich
which is quite fun been doing that for a
while
and
today
i will
tell you a bit
why
you should listen to me
by luck or bad luck
i've been in several situations in my
life that has driven me to be the
troubled shooter i don't know how many
of you have ever been into trouble
shooting investigating a problem that
nobody knows why that is happening
i've been there well quite a lot so you
know the pain right
so i've been doing that for a lot of
time until they got me jose like
they put me the head of a troubleshooter
to find the issues and to fix them well
right for a while
and yeah i don't know if it's slack or
not but sometimes life puts you in very
complicated situations
and what i'm going to show is you is one
of them that you may think initially it
has nothing related
to personal testing but
this is my bathroom
this is one week from now
what would have happened
if
it got me
washing my teeth
for example
it wouldn't have been nice
technicians came
and they saw in the upper right that
this was caused by a leak
and they suddenly investigated a bit
more
so they opened up
and so the the pipes which
if you think about that if you think as
an apartment
as a micro service as a container or
microservice and the pipelines
as a messaging pipeline it sort of makes
sense there was a leak there that had
been going for a while
the infrastructure here was several
damage
and they had to reinforce it so i was
lucky not to be there i was lucky nobody
died and that just happened one week ago
i think it was a perfect sample
later on
the technicians came
and did these
this is a bit of duct taping but you are
familiar with that right
and
this is a pipeline and it's not glue so
it's a we can't call it staging right
so they did testing not simple testing
they didn't drop one drop one message to
see if it works they did it as it should
be
they put and call all the buildings and
say hey now open and flush whatever
you're doing
in there and see if it works sometimes
it's the only way and the best way to
determine if this system will work in
real life
later on they put almost in production
disease was sent to me like yesterday
so i hope
it will be all right and not happen
again
so this kind of situations have happened
to me for a while and i'm shaped a bit
in performance testing troubleshooting
analysis of code muslin.net since 2004
so kind of
the kind of person that
i'm very stubborn i have a friend
michael stapp
he's a german but he told me hey jose
you are more german than any other
german that i know even me and sorry i'm
spanish no german so i'm that kind of
stubborn i get to one thing and i don't
let it go until
it's done
my girlfriend hates it
all right
so today we are going to see
why you should do performance testing
well seeing the amount of people you're
already convinced and that performance i
think is important right but this
session i'll give you some points that
you can convince your boss
if he you tell him i think we should do
performance testing he'd probably come
back and say sorry we don't have budget
so i'll help you convince them i'll tell
you
why i pick up k6 what are my reasons
i'll give you a handsome introduction to
k6
and i'll show you the template you'll
see that later
so first of all why should you be
testing at all there's some people that
don't see value on testing they say it
costs money
and it works right
um basically you can avoid human
mistakes by fully automatic things
and if you all in health you work in
health care or in finance it can be
mandatory in some cases
as well as well it increases the quality
or you can ensure that the quality is
there
and that it will not break with
and you can identify the effects
regularly
and will reduce flows and avoid the new
flows are added when you change and
refactor your code
so i think it's important and
everybody is doing with the pyramid
i don't know if you have work with uh
what's the name performance test leader
test leader
test manager they do the plan and the
plan is perfect and the plan usually
follows that the pyramid where you have
a lot of tests in the unit test then you
have a less integration company usually
they don't do
and then some integration tests and at
the end maybe if you're lucky they will
do end-to-end tests or ui tests
and that's everything because as you go
up it costs money
and apart from that
usually you find nothing more even in
serious projects that are regulated
in a health environment
it's very sad because here there is a
big problem
anybody can see the problem here
everything here is functional you are
mostly testing for one single user but
what if you have 100 users simultaneous
or 100 services attacking your
microservice or api
well thing changes right
but well you know perfect lives if you
don't do that things will happen and
performance tests are key
to identify real life issues
in fact it's the only way
it's as close as reality as you can get
there was a system under development i
think it was six years we were into it
together with a collector was supposed
to sit in front of me now but you know
he was group b so
not here
sadly and
norman and me were on the project
hi norman
and
after six years they decided to put the
database under the full load it had to
have in production after six years
and that's what happened murphy lives
and they discovered quite a several set
of issues there
that took
one year or more than one year for one
architect and a team dedicated several
months to mitigate it but they have to
delay that for one year
and the commercial losses everything
just the mitigation cost a bit more than
two million dollars
if that sounds like a lot of money wait
for the next the note 7 battery costed
70 million dollars not bad right
and well
apart from that it's not only money some
people
kind of almost lose their legs or
somebody lose their legs so it's uh well
i think that's more serious than than
the money i think nobody died but there
were serious injuries and people will
have to endure pain for lives
and you don't want your software to do
that right
and
well if you test in production
i don't have to remind you that
you know it very well
another example anybody knows
night night i don't know if it's night
investments i think there was a session
some days ago it was mentioned by dylan
beatty i think you have seen the video
everywhere these days is fantastic
speaker
and knight had a problem problem
they deployed
a release without testing that had a
flag i think the power pack was called
and that caused in
like kind of every minute that the
system was leaking some kind of orders
that were not prepared that this kind of
flag was triggering
this trigger i think it was 10 million
dollars per minute so at the end it was
close to half a billion dollar 500
million wow
well
still nothing close to lose your life
and well
at the end performance testing can avoid
all of these it's worth it ensures
reliability and your project success
shows how brittle it is when you put the
expected load in users or data
and verifies sla slas and service level
agreements
that
you're lucky if you have them otherwise
this test you can say okay
my api my web response in 300
milliseconds and that's your sla give it
or take it if you want it better let us
know
at least you turn the table around and
you tell your manager that's the sla it
covers you want more
give us money for more developers that
usually doesn't work
and we'll save money a lot of money
because it reduces the risk
and if
you detect them as close as you produce
them and you implement performance
testing from day zero
well you know you see that there's a
studies that show that as soon as you
detect it it's easier and cheaper to fix
in the case of an apartment or a
building
if the parliament is on the main
infrastructure
well it would take quite a few days but
if they detect it right away it's just a
swap
it's all right
so and most of more important it saves
us from stress
we all want to live happily and develop
code that works and we deploy we go home
we know we don't have to be there the
weekend right because we have tested it
properly
and as well
this is daring but
i truly believe your software can save
life if you work in healthcare can save
people from
a false positive or falsity which you
know i don't know if you suffer that but
some time ago last year my girlfriend
had two false positives with a copy test
and she was super healthy and i was
completely negative so i asked for a
retest because i was in the pcr and i
know they are not 90
perfect
and the people hunting at well there's
human mistakes
so we don't want that to happen and
testing is one way to solve
it hope you are not convinced that
performance testing is important
and i'll tell you why you should try k6
how many of you have tried k6 or know
what k6 is
raise your hands i know it a bit
one two three yeah not everybody
k6 is a company that started as a gaming
company
and
they wanted to do like an mmo rpg
but
they had some performance problems and
they implemented a performance test
suite and that turned out to be so good
that they converted all their business
into that
really they they also had two alligators
and that's true
you can go to k6 dot io and watch it
it's funny story my decision points
there where performance was pretty good
um it is they have an open source
version and it's kept really really
really well
it's based on code so you don't depend
on any ui to define your test
and you can integrate first this
test into your pipeline
in a ci cd pipeline azure repos for
example
and it's really easy to do that we will
see how to do that later
it has many outputs and integrations and
if there is not the one you want
it is extensible they have extensibility
options that they did i think
like seven or eight months ago that's
pretty open and the community is vibrant
talking about community i was talking to
nicole nicole is a developer evangelist
from kasich and also
with floor floor dress maybe you know it
she was a developer evangelist microsoft
that recently joined
k6 and
they told me hey why don't we do that
you make some questions to the audience
and if they respond properly we will
send
three swag kids from k6 i think there's
a t-shirt
a nice bag
some stickers
i think i got one here yep k-6
and if you want that put attention i'll
make you questions three questions
and the person that gets it right the
first
well
you come later tell me your name i write
it down and your email
and i'll send that to nicole and floor
and they will get you
a kit
that's what keep
all right
so and they have a lot of more things
they are evolving the system like crazy
they were also acquired recently by
grafana an observability platform which
is pretty cool and they have a strong
focus in open source
and
yeah and they recently announced that
they opened like a performance test
suite
for attacking or
doing tests against a ui to html ui
kind of similar to other platforms i
will not mention but the good thing is
it's highly performant because it does
not depend on a ui that i know i still
have not really fully checked
it's also very modern so it was designed
built about five years ago
and they are not stopping the ones in
red before you ask are the ones that
depend on a ui
so they are ui driven so if the ui
changes
the generated file that they use may
change so you may lose some format or
functionality so that's your own risk
it's really active so it has a lot of
comments and they release really really
very frequently
and they have a very good performance
to rps before you ask it's a request per
second so this is a bit old
and what i like is the ratio comparison
of the the one in
orange is the memory usage so it's
quite quite good it's not the best phone
but what i was looking is a good
equilibrium between fissures
ease of use that it's code it can
integrate with my
azure devops
and
yeah that means i put that in my project
i'll show you in a moment
later so
and that's why i pick up k6 and i think
it's a fantastic option for you
now i'll jump into a bit of coding
and i'll show you
how to do things with k6 i'll show you
how we can begin working with it
how
does it work what's the lifetime of a k6
script
how can we
simulate a user verify do one check how
we can do a test which is important
and then
the meat of the matter how to simulate
real-world load
how to simulate a user or api that works
with your system
so
let's get to it
i'll switch
can you see properly the code
at the end
perfect
so here i have a hello world script what
better way by the way k6 was was built
on go so it's the language but the
scripts you create are on
javascript sorry about that
not my decision i like them to be on
c-sharp
you cannot have everything right
so here what we do is we import http
model the sleep because we want the user
not to be like 555 super quick
and then we do
there is a
default function which is what it will
do by default
and i'm doing a request here to this
address which is a test api endpoint
that
i asked permission token hey can i use
that for my demos i tell ya sure go
ahead they don't know what they are
doing because i have a demo later on
that will kick there
strongly
so how does it look
so before that
yeah
you need to install it i have it already
installed but i'll show you how to do it
so you go to k6. you go to open source
because this is what i'm focusing today
you go to download
in this case to windows
and
you can do use chocolaty or simply
install the msi package execute it
install it on next exactly it's like one
minute
once you have that installed
you can execute that in either piece of
studio in a terminal
[Music]
let's go there
with k6 and run
just it needs to be in lower case
and you can put the name of the script
yeah not the proper folder and that you
don't see too much so i will switch to
command prompt
yeah nice
so this is what you see when you execute
the strip in this case it's a very
simple one
but here
you see the local can be local if you
execute it on your machine or can be
cloud if you use their lock their cloud
services
just keep your executing
some data the iterations
and here on the running you can see the
time it took the the be used the us
stands for virtual user
that they are simulating and the
iterations that have complete and
interrupted and here you have like a
kind of progress bar that's really
helpful
then you can see the data received
sent
and
http request duration this important one
and you have a trend what they call a
trend here
here
you have a statistic that shows the
average minimum maximum and the mean oh
sorry the median and then a percentage
of the 90 percent
of 95 percent and at the bottom
the bit of how much the
iterations took
and the iterations iterations is the
request that the virtual users have
issued
right and here they build the users
nothing more pretty simple
just saying if any of you have any
questions just
say it i'm happy to be interrupted
then the next question is how do things
happen here what's the lifetime i have
another example for you
here
this is
simple
execution i'm going to make it small so
we can see it more
so first is
some declarations some imports then you
can put some code this code will be
executed as well before anything and
then you have to set up the setup is
where
what is going to happen at the beginning
where you can do a set up your test data
you can do a login and get the token
that all the other executions can use
if you don't want to do the logging as
part of the test of course
and or prepare the data auto load your
data put that in a place that the other
test scripts
the default function all the concrete
functions
will use
and at the end you have a teardown
that is where you can clean that data to
leave everything
very clean
let's see how this runs
lifetime
you can see
here
on this part
where i put in the logs
how things are happening which makes
sense just saying that the setup will
happen once the tier down once but the
vo code it happens according you have 10
views working you you will print that
for
a lot of times
right
then another concept is
how do i boot okay that's good for one
user for one call but what if i want 10
users hitting the server for 10 seconds
right
what if i want to check that the time
is good so the the calls for this volume
of users
is under 500 milliseconds or 200 depends
on what you need and
that the system is responding properly
so you have these concepts
you have first the options object
which is where you configure everything
in k6
in this object you define what are the
views
in this case you say okay i want three
virtual users i want this to take six
seconds
and then on the default function
and you get the result you can do a
check
you have to import it so
first
and then you can check things like at
the status of the http responses 200
everything went okay all that the
duration was under 500 milliseconds
let's see that
one in action
here you can see
the evolution
of the progress bar and the pus as well
here you have everything was green
we are happy
we got the duration that now went from
minimum of 100 up to 200 change a bit
right
and the views and 15 iterations we did
15 records we're getting bigger
another thing is
these checks are not a test pass fail
for doing a pass fail test you need to
do a threshold
which you do as well in the options
let's take a look at that
here
in the thresholds i set up a collection
of elements in this case i'm doing a
http registration which has a threshold
that says 90
must be under 200 milliseconds
and another that all the checks
must pass
90 so i must have all the all the checks
passing more than 90
and the rest is exactly the same
yep
let's do it
this is quite quick five seconds you can
see the progress bar going you know
already how it goes and now
here
you see that the thresholds
are passed so the test is green if you
put that in actual devops you would get
yeah thumbs up i'm happy
you don't get much more in
usher at the moment
here
so
what more
now we have
the power to do very simple things but
we want more right we want to simulate
real life
output what if for example in an office
you have a system that works and gives
some kind of service to the office
workers
and you know that they come at the
office about eight between eight and
nine
so they are ramping up some people may
be early maybe at seven
and but usually it's about eight that
they start coming in usually it's a bit
smooth because you know we have a
bottleneck the doors the elevators
so what we do is we use stages
stages as you may guess those gaining
options
and i really like it
here
you have a collection of elements that
determine
okay
that
in time
i want five
users mutual users in this case then i
want three seconds
with ten users and then five and then
one so you are determining in a very
clear way
how your users will scale
let's take a look at that in action
five stages yes
so you can see
here
how it's scaling
oops
yeah i stopped it and now it's ramping
down
so it's how it works you put the target
and it runs down and then it ramps up
and then this fail well
can't happen
now we know how to determine our users
the next thing we do is
to be able to control what they are
doing users will not simply go to a url
and click f5 f5 f5 to the same url
you want to determine that for example
you have bob and bob likes to go to
check
what's new on
the selling page of your company
and you have john and john will go to
see the tasks that he has to do for the
day he likes to do everything well and
for that you have scenarios
which as you can guess
it goes again in options and changes a
bit the rules this the thing so this is
the main thing that changes so you set
up the scenarios which is a collection
of different scenarios which is an
object that has an exec this is the name
of the function of javascript that it
will invoke
and then it has the executor the
executor is
in this case ramping views which is
virtual users they will ramp up and wrap
down
and then you have the start time and the
start views you can control everything
of course you have stages
so with that
you can do absolutely anything in this
case i have two which one is
simple function
and the other is also ramping views that
starts three seconds later
one will start with one virtual user the
other with two
one will take five seconds the other
will take two seconds
and if we run it you can see now that we
are seeing here
the two running in parallel with the
progress bar
that was too quick maybe
and
that's it
nothing more
that's cool right
for me what i like the most is that you
can determine
what they are doing if you put the names
properly
it's really visible so that's one of the
things that made me choose this
technology versus other that
can't have
about double even of performance but
with this you see the code and you know
what this is doing sorry
okay
i really like it do you like it
cool i'm happy
all right
so
there's one commit here is uh
this is sex it's ugly right
so let's do something about that
i think it's yeah
so
k6 was acquired recently i think it's
about two or three months ago by grafana
but this does not have anything to do
on that
on the open source project
k6 brings us already
some kind of uh solution for that it
brings a docker compose um yes you are
all familiar with that probably file i
think it's
if we go to
here to the github repo
we have a nice
docker compose that will set up influx
db database and
graphana container
in fact i have already installed and set
up there so i will save that part
yeah so i have that and this so i have
even database and i have graffana
and
yeah
that enables me to send the output from
k6
to this
influx database and then i have already
configured
uh this
dashboard graphana for toast i don't
know
it's a observability platform that
enables us to create dashboards between
many other things that i will not go
into so one of these dashboards created
by k6 is this one it's pretty pretty
good
and then what i do is when i connect
here i import and put the link to this
one
and i simply load it and then i can use
it
have it already here let me clean that
up and put the last five minutes
so you can see there's nothing
and the only thing i need to do
i will clean this up so it looks better
i had it on there
yeah this one so i will run the stages
and i will derive the output to the
influx cb which is hosted locally in my
docker
so here we don't see much
but if we go there
and it works
yeah it works nice
we can zoom it a bit and we can see a
bit
the evolution and also check the checks
and see how it behaves at the end it
went a bit higher don't know why
so this is a bit
source of okay
so this is how we can have a nice output
to
put in a power point or presentation to
show your bosses how your system
performs
then
maybe we like to integrate that
with our
azure devops pipeline right
so
let's get that done
i have a rep here
where i created a folder
and i put a performance script
this is the template i
will explain in a moment so i will not
type into it but this is a k6 script
and then i have a
yaml file which is also in the code
and for this
i have set up
here
so i will edit from the proper place
can you read it properly at the bottom
all right
cool
this is doing nothing it's very stupid
but the only thing he's doing is
publishing
as a less artifact the script so here
i'm checking if the directory
performance exists and if it exists i
will set the variable performance to
true based on this variable
i check next
in a publish build artifact that if you
work a bit with azure devops you should
probably know it
and if the variable performance is true
then i publish
this path performance as per test as a
build artifact
so we can use it later on as it's part
of the build
it's a nice way to do it
then
on the releases but
i'll make your question first for this
walk
how do i call or how do i execute k6
what are the two instructions that go
first
who wants to go and say it
who was that
yep perfect the next one is
perfect
that you come later i get your name and
i put you in contact with k6 people and
they send you a bunch of stuff all right
so
if i edit this release pipeline
here i have the typical
continuous build integration
where is trigger
whenever
a release is created new build
here as well after the release to these
and here i have a job that has three
tasks and runs
on linux in ubuntu concretely not on
windows
and here i have three tasks one of them
is installing k6
and all these that you see here i'm
taking that from
literally the installation i showed you
before but in this case from linux so
it's this piece of code
nothing more
then i do another which i check if k6 is
installed if this doesn't work i don't
need to do the test
and then i do the test in this case i
will do a shake down test shake down
is a test with a low amount of data
that is meant to check the system
stability
so i'm doing it a bit of a kind of an
end to it test
but a bit harder than really just
testing one user or one iteration
and usually what i do is i do that for
two minutes to ten minutes
and sometimes it's about 100 users it
depends on the search on the system
right
and do i do this before
any deployment to staging so i deploy
first to that per state
to the depth environment and then i can
test that there some people like to do
also on the staging
it can be done
here what i have is also k6 run
the name of the script and then
something more
this minus e is the way of k6 to give it
environment variables which is the
perfect chance to give it some variables
that i have defined on the azure
pipeline like
which stairs do i want to run
which environment i want this test to
run on and your
test
if you write it a bit smart can react on
it so you don't have to write a test for
anything and the same test will do
everything
the other test that we could do is load
test which is to test the load that you
expect on the system for
some time like half an hour one hour
maybe one day depends
we can do also soak testing
or endurance testing which is testing
for a while
for one day or two days
in healthcare for example you have some
rules that you have to keep a system
working without any delay any stop for
one week
so that kind of makes sense you need to
do that in some cases
and then
i give it some username and password to
authenticate and these are put here in
variables
the environment to run is visible i want
a test i want a smoke test
and the password and username are
private they are
encrypted
so they are stored in a secure location
in azure cable in this case
good
and when we execute that
i'll show you the good one
no not here locks
you see the execution
and
this sounds familiar it is a bit more
webos when you execute it in the cloud
but at the end
you get more or less the same here it
has a bit more configuration more things
but
you can see the http requisition with
some more detail
and this is how you integrate that with
azure devops
one more thing which is cool
is
cloud anybody yeah
this template i show you
is part of
swiss life open source where i work i'm
lucky to work there
here um
this open source initiative was created
by philippe baum that was supposed to be
here but he got into plainly hi philip
and
his leading also is my team lead so i
need to
well um
now he's fantastic he codes he's the
trickiest one of all us so he's
amazing
so being in his team is a honor
and he single-handedly
created this initiative and is coding
like weekends creating open source uh
this is a way that we are doing
innovation we are doing innovation in
more than one way but this is one way
that we are doing innovation in swiss
life and i'm happy to say that two of
them have recently reached 600 000
downloads and they are pretty cool if
you work in dotnet you may want to check
them
we have a squadron which was created in
a big way by phillip also marius
matissek
was
working on it several and other
colleagues from us
snapshooper was created by a friend of
mine norman scheiber and
yeah
there
well i could name all the persons in the
team because all of them are doing
amazing things but if you are interested
in testing check
squadron
it's a container management that can
do for you a lot of work and simulate a
lot of cloud services mostly usher
sorry but we like microsoft we work with
actually hey brandon
you're happy
good
so one of them a very small them is this
one this is the multi-scenario template
this is
a bit of what i was defining to work a
bit like the template that we're using
to create our test the trace life
and i make it a bit clean and took a bit
the internal parts to make it
usable for third parties and this is
already
working showing how to integrate with
other services how to do authentication
how to put a token in the header and
also how to use graphql and check that
the request is responding properly and
check
how is your graphql behaving
so check it i think it's interesting it
also shows a bit how to do ui testing
even that's not the goal of k6
but it's pretty cool
let me show you a bit
so i go back here
i have it here here
and i've created like a two scenarios
concrete scenarios
but let me show it a bit to you
so
here i have
a lot more things that you haven't seen
i'm handling the arguments with some
default arguments that usually will do
nothing
and some tests to run an environment to
run
some internal management for
and there i did create some sample and
custom metrics which is also important
for counters and for trends and then the
execution type execution type is what i
just mentioned before it's the kind of
test you want to execute you can set and
use your same test with the same
executors to do a load test to do a soak
test to do a stress test
or in this our case an ndc load an ndc
stress test which we are going to do
right now
these are a bit harder than usual
so i wanted to play around with the test
services from k6 they kindly let me
break them a bit
so that's nice
and here
in this case i have a back and read
scenario that's simply reading
information from a res service
i'm using ramping arrival rate in this
case this is important because
bu
you have a user
and that may be a problem because a user
if you are a user you request for
information
and your system under test is
slow
you are still waiting until the
information comes back and you cannot do
anything else that's a user and when you
contract you can do another request but
the problem here is that the vu
is inherently affected by the
performance of the system it has to test
and maybe you don't want that
what i like in this case is to use the
arrival rate arrival rate says oh you
have to do one records per second
and you will do exactly that if you need
more users
the system will have a pool of users
that will reduce the users sorry users
and create and destroy them as he needs
to do exactly that and it will ensure
that you do a request every second or
whenever you want
is that clear
perfect
good
so here i have a start time zero time
unit is one second i will start with 10
iterations per second and i pre-allocate
650 users this is getting serious and i
will start 20 seconds
with 50 users then ramping up 120 and
then 140.
that's a low test that's not the biggest
one and then i will do another operation
which
some a lot of users will only consume
information
um but this will be like 90 or 95
and some users will also modify
information that's what i'm doing here
this i will upload later in github it's
already on the github that i show you
it's bithub.com slash switch live menus
oss slash k6 multi scenario template
so because i'm lazy i put that before
and i tested everything
so this i'm doing you know c that's to
run ndc load
i want it an output to influx a b so we
will see graphically and
let's oops no
i was not in the right directory that's
essentially it
and this load yes now it works
now you can see the progress it's
initializing here the users
and now it's starting
it's ramping up
by iterations
this template i also put some login that
you can disable or enable and in this
case it's a public service that
can easier go so there is no problem
with showing the token usually don't do
that please
you can be fired if you do that
and
then
here we are going this test takes about
50 seconds
and
now you can see we are reaching
more volume than usual
they told me that about
100 requests per second it starts to
break so i try not to
do that
so i was playing until
so there is that the low test works well
but the stress test
the stresses usually are used for
trying or detecting where are the limits
of your system what's the maximum
throughput you can get
and also usually you detect where the
weakest point in your system is
that's a good thing
what depends on what you find right
all right so it went green and
everything is beautiful
so we did here
about 3500
iterations
we
did quite a bit of five we received
about five megabytes of data we send
about one megabyte
well everything went green
and if we observe it
with
these let me
trigger it to five minutes
you can see that this has another
perspective right
we saw that when it
here we had a drop
of performance
or there were less requests so
that's a bit curious
and let's check so maybe we should take
a look into that
and also
when we were ramping up we had some
times that we reached one second and
it is quite good i got even to four
seconds sometime
so that was not that bad even the rest
much time over time it increased which
is not ideal maybe we want maybe to
scale it or to put more servers if we
want to smooth out and
enable that we are quite under 200
milliseconds it depends on what your sls
are
so now we are going to do the bad guy
the stress test
i'm here pre-allocating almost 3 000
virtual users in the pool
i'm starting with 20 star rate and i'm
reaching up to 340
iterations per second
backing flow i don't show it it's still
small
so let's do it
this is stress
see if i can write it properly
what what i like about the template is
that you have everything in one single
script and
it enables a lot of reusability
if it was c sharp
other things could be applied but well
with javascript i think it's one of the
best ways to do it
let's
now it's initializing so
this part you have seen and let me move
here
and i will do one thing so we don't see
the other
and i will say that i want from that
moment to now
i think it was like that
doesn't change
okay whatever i'll wait until it's done
so it's
20 seconds to go
no errors at the moment
i will see oh we got one effort oops
that was expected
so uh stress test gives you
a
a shape of how it's
okay that was word i should not touch it
i think it's done
so let's get here
last few minutes
and if we look at that we see that
we reach for seconds and it went higher
so we definitely need to look into
what's happening because it can be
unacceptable
second question what's the even database
that
i was using
on the container with k6 and grafana
yep good you got it
i have only one more question so be
attentive
so uh well i hope you like the example i
think it definitely defines a bit
clearly
and sometimes you don't see that in in
the code
you can see if you look at their yeah
you definitely see okay this
request duration took sometimes 28
seconds that's a clear significant
something when
not okay and you need to look into that
but the data is not as visual as a nice
graphic and it can help a lot so i
recommend you do both
apart from that
the template is here and if you are
curious i encourage you to download it
clone it
even to do a pull request if you think
of a feature that
you cannot or if you see something is
not working
you can also
create an issue
with that
the talk is done
as a takeaway is
i would tell you to do performance
testing
unless you want costly surprises
you know murphy lives
and you can damage your users and you
don't want that you can make them lose
money you can then have a
get them to have a bad experience
stress for you
if there's an issue and the user that
actually guess
if it's a weekend and you are there for
that guess what will happen
and probably happened before right
i've been
several weekends working and fixing
things that were not tested properly who
else has been awakened there working
yeah one two three
i feel you
and the second thing is you have to
convince whoever is in the lead to do
that from the beginning put a
performance test even your system is not
complete i did that in a further project
in
company was and said the name then let
me do it and
we find a database defect similar to the
one we found in the other project six
years it took one year
and some months to fix to mitigate
in this case it took one week
to fix of only one person
think about that
and k6 is good use k6 i don't get
anything from k6 i'm not part of k6 i
just use the software and i like it
and try the k6 template if you like you
are welcome to contribute back
and of course try swiss life open source
if you are into testing you are into net
you have squadron you have snap shooter
you have a lot of other
open source tools that may be of help to
you and they are free and we are using
them in production
so
that was it thank you very much it was a
pleasure to have so much people here
it's quite amazing i was not expecting
that
before
i have a last question because i need to
give a third kind of swag
um
who can tell me
what is
soak testing
load testing
no
okay um
where
what is the company that i used to show
the graphical
view
perfect you got it
so that was it thank you everybody it
was amazing to be here with you
[Applause]
so you have any questions
yeah it's like a virtual separate and
isolated process that acts as a user
doing whatever you want to do in that
either default function or the function
that you name
yeah
does it respond to your question perfect
i don't know if
more questions
everything was clear
so
i'll be looking at the slack if anybody
has another question so
thank you very much
you